all right i reread the question and now
i realize what with the error in my
logic
i misread the question i had misread and
i said oh there are 7 60 siblings no
there are 60 sibling pairs
60 sibling pairs
pairs so that means in each class
they're so 60 sibling pairs that means
there are 120 siblings but that tells us
that in each class there aren't 30 there
are 60 members of a sibling group
right so let's go back through our logic
again
let's say i pick someone from the junior
class first what is the probability that
i even pick someone from a sibling pair
was going to be 60
over 1000
which is the same thing as 6 over 100
which is the same thing as three over
fifty right
fair enough so there's a three and fifty
chance that i pick someone who's a
member of a sibling pair
now in order for me to have a complete
sibling pair when i go to the senior
class and pick someone i have to p pick
this junior sibling and that junior only
has one sibling in the senior class so
there's only one in 800 chance that i
picked their sibling it doesn't matter
that there are other six the other 59
siblings in that are useless because
they're not this guy's sibling
so i have a 1 in 800 chance of doing
that and you multiply them you get 3
over
40 000
and that's choice a
you don't see your choice make sure to
read the question again
i'm almost out of space let me clear all
of this
let me clear all of that
and we're on problem 218
218.
which of the following cannot be the
median of the three positive integers
x
y and z so the median the middle number
they say hey well a is x well no that's
not true what if this was the order x y
z then x would be the median
so it's not a
b z no reason why z can't be the median
the order can be y z x it's not b
c
x plus z
well let's see could x plus z
be the median
x plus z could that be the median
so let me think about it
if if we have x
z
and y
i mean by definition one of these
numbers have to be the median we have
three numbers one of them has to be the
middle number under what circumstances
because x plus
i mean if x plus z is the medium that
implies that x z has to be that neither
x nor z is the median right do they tell
us that those are right they're positive
integers none of these are zero
so in order for x plus z to be the
median that tells us that
that neither x nor z is the median right
and if neither x nor z is the median
then y has to be the median and then
that tells us that x plus z
has to be equal to y
but if y is a median the order is this x
y z
and there's no way that i can add x and
z
and get a smaller number than z because
all of these numbers are positive
right yeah they say three positive
integers so i go with choice c that
cannot happen the median cannot be
x plus z
problem 219.
what is the 25th digit
to the right of the decimal point
in the decimal form of 6 over 11.
whenever they ask you for something
ridiculous there must be some type of
pattern we can exploit to figure out
what the 25th digit is so let's just
start dividing
goes into 6 we're going to have to have
some
decimals there
11 goes into 60 5 times
5 times 11 is 55
and then remainder 5 then you go into 50
you get a 4
4 times i already see the pattern 44
oh no never mind but let me make sure
that right that's right
you get 50 remainder 11 goes into 50
four times you get 40
so then you get a 60 11 goes into 60
five times
and you repeat so on and so forth so the
first so i just want to make sure you
see the first digit to the right is 25
the second digit to the right is 4 the
third digit to the right is 5
and so you know we could keep going the
fourth digit to the right is 4. so every
odd digit to the right of this is what
it's 5. so they want to know the 25th
digit to the right and that's an odd
number 25 so it has to be 5 as well so
that's choice c
next question
question
oh i thought i'd erase that okay
question 220
220.
john and mary were each paid x dollars
in advance to do a certain job together
fair enough john worked on the job for
10 hours so john worked 10 hours
and mary worked two hours less than john
so mary worked eight hours right john
worked in the job for 10 hours and mary
worked two hours less than john so she
worked eight hours if mary gave y
dollars of her payment so that they
would have received the same hourly wage
what was the dollar amount in terms of
why that john was paid in advance
okay john and mary were each paid x
dollars in advance to do a certain job
together
okay so how much money did they so john
got x dollars and mary got x dollars
they both got x dollars right
so if you think about it
let's let's ignore who did what right we
had how many total hours of labor we had
18 hours of labor
and they were paid how many dollars they
were paid two x dollars
so they were paid two x
they were paid two x dollars right for
18 hours of labor
so the average
wage
should be
you can kind of view it the the fair you
know per hourly wage should be
let's see we could divide by nine
get a one and you get a nine you get x
over nine
x over nine
dollars per hour
what was x over nine
dollars
per hour
that's the fair wage let me read the
question if mary gave john y dollars of
our payment so that they would have had
the same hourly rate wage what was the
dollar amount in terms of why that john
was paid
in advance
actually let's think of it this way
so mary pays john let me ignore this i
just thought of a better way of doing it
so they each
each we're each paid x dollars in
advance to a certain job john worked on
the job for 10 hours and mary worked two
hours less than john
if mary paid john y dollars of her
payment so that they would have received
the same hourly wage so after mary pays
john y what so that means john got a
total of y dollars and mary
has
paid y dollars so now john has x plus y
and mary has x minus y dollars
and so if mary paid of her payment so
that they would receive the same hourly
wage
what was the dollar amount in terms of
why that john was paid in advance that
john was paid in advance
so let me think about this a little bit
so they got the same they received the
same hourly wage so
they essentially
marry so mary should have eight tenths
the money of john right
so
x minus y
should be equal to
point eight
times x plus y
am i thinking about that right or is
there an easier way to think about it
well let's think about it this way john
worked two hours more than mary right
however
so mary essentially if she pays him for
one hours
no then then
if she
you know yeah this is the right thing x
minus y is equal to 0.8 times x plus y
but i'm going to still up end up with an
x here so you get x
minus y is equal to 0.8
x
plus 0.8y right and all the logic here i
just said is well mary's total money if
we're going to be fair should be 0.8 of
john's total money because she worked
0.8 as much hours
and so let's see oh actually they want
to know what john was paying in advance
so that's x so they actually okay we're
fine so they just want to know what x is
in terms of y so we're cool so let's
subtract point eight x from both sides
so you get point two x
minus y
is equal to point eight y
and then add y to both sides you get
point two x is equal to
1.8y
and then multiply both sides by 5
you get x is equal to what is that 5
times 18 is 50 plus 40. add a decimal
point that's 90 is equal to 9y and that
is choice e i got a little confused with
the wording of it when they say what was
the dollar amount in terms of why that
john was paid in advance they should
have said
what was x it would have been a little
bit easier anyway i'm all out of time
sorry for bumbling through that problem
see in the next video